hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the monday morning podcast
for monday
may 2nd
2022 what's going on how
are ya
how's it going
everybody i hope you had a nice weekend
i hope you had a nice rest of your april
because now
we are into may man
we are into [ __ ] make which means
what what does may mean it means
kentucky derby
what they do to those horses is horrible
they're not midgets they're little
people do
look at that [ __ ] lady face playing
over there um the kentucky derby
everybody
what's going on that's gonna be uh was
the first saturday in may and then you
got mother's day
you know gotta get uh you gotta call
your mom that day you gotta get her some
seas candies
some flowers or whatever
you know buy your wife something shiny
and then what then the rest of the month
is for you
this is a good month man
and i always try to remind myself this
is the beginning of the summer even
though summer doesn't start
until june i always feel like the summer
goes flying by and i go what the [ __ ]
happened the summer's over
and i always sleepwalk through may
well guess what that ain't they ain't
happen they happen in this may
all right
i have a little splash about pool i'm
gonna get in it you know
i'm gonna swim some [ __ ] you know
half a laps
in my glorified kiddie pool
um
i've been telling you this story about
my pool
oh it's a funny one you know always make
sure you jump into a pool before you buy
the house
uh you know always make sure you make
sure that the [ __ ] the the the
goddamn thing that's supposed to heat up
isn't from [ __ ] 9 000 years ago it
doesn't even work always make sure you
do that always make sure if you go you
know what that [ __ ] heating thing
keeps breaking down what if i buy one of
these solar things what if i buy one of
these solar [ __ ] things to put over
my [ __ ]
pool
and then you the first time you use it
it's incredible it's like getting in
bath water and then the second time it
doesn't even work anymore and then you
then find out
that
too much exposure to the sun can damage
a solar
pool cover
it doesn't even that doesn't make any
[ __ ] sense
that's like buying a baseball bat where
baseballs can hurt the bat well i guess
they break the bat
all right maybe it does make sense all
right you know what i'm not as mad at my
solar panel as i was before
my solar nut panel my solar pool cover
which is basically a little bit bigger
than your average afghan because uh i
don't know
it's technically not a pool um
no it's not that bad i'm [ __ ] with
you
it's a nice one
you know
but i'd like to be in it this year so
that's what i'm doing okay every weekend
i'm getting out there you know like
chevy chase this is crazy this is crazy
this is crazy in vacation and i'm doing
a [ __ ] cannonball like [ __ ] um
what's his face an anchorman
ron burgundy
i start with the chubby chase from
vacation this is crazy this is crazy
crazy then i am with the ron burgundy
and then i come up like that kid
who saw the doo-doo and [ __ ] in the pool
in uh caddyshack that's how i do it i go
old school
uh bill what in the [ __ ] are you
babbling about i don't know i've been i
got into the red sox and i'm watching
them and they just they [ __ ] they're
losing to the blue jays they were
playing the orioles i'm like okay
you know
let's wake up the bats here
we [ __ ] score three runs right off
the bat the first game and we don't
score any more runs we end up winning uh
three this was that game three to
something
i can't remember we lost like one to
nothing then i was watching like a
couple nights ago
and we were winning the game one nothing
the whole [ __ ] game
this [ __ ] guy gives us seven strong
innings what the hell uh nathan avaldi
seven strong innings and then we come in
in the eighth inning
we [ __ ] give up a run it's tied
they've blown so many games at this
point i still believe in them i still
love them but we've blown so many
[ __ ] games i'm trying to remember how
we blew this this one
was it the bottom of the ninth
no it wasn't it was the bottom of the
eighth
they tied it up 1-1 and then we had the
bottom of our order to go up in the
ninth we went down in order i believe
they [ __ ] came up we stopped them then
the tenth ending we had runners at the
corner we couldn't do it and then this
[ __ ] guy
laid down a bunk
and our pitcher ran up to go get it and
he went to go to throw to third and he
[ __ ] overthrew the guy and uh was it
baltimore's center fielder
just named cedric mullins came in and
won the game and i'm just like this was
the [ __ ] series we're supposed to try
to get back because the yankees
and and uh and i can't say the blue jays
they've been kicking rs but the yankees
you know had a a nice schedule so far
and i'm like good we're gonna start
playing the teams that they were playing
and we're gonna win and at least you
know not lose any more ground and
we ended up losing again today we lost
it was nine to one we scored four runs
in the top of the ninth and
we lost nine to five
so i don't know
but i gotta be honest with you i like
that i'm into baseball this early you
know
fill in the [ __ ] cracks as
the celtics lose game one
to the milwaukee bucks and the bruins
start game one uh their their playoff
run
tomorrow actually tonight
when you're listening to this against
the carolina hurricanes who i still
remember a long time ago
even though i believe we avenged that
loss
we played them in the [ __ ] playoffs
and they scored this overtime
goal to close out the playoff series
and i just remember that hurricane guy
skating down doing his jazz hands
he had his hands in the air going like
ah
made it even worse
so we'll see how we do
we will see how we do uh old freckles is
still going along with the tour i got
the uh the netflix thing this week uh
i'm doing a show at the uh the la forum
uh very excited to be doing that i got
my act where it needs to be and the
other night
you know i was driving down the street
and i saw i went by the hollywood bowl
and i saw dave chappelle and friends i
was like holy [ __ ] i would love to go
see dave do an hour
at the hollywood bowl
so i called up a
couple of people there big bang boom and
then they're like hey you want to do a
little time in front of him and i was
like oh boy would i
so i got to do 15 minutes in front of
dave chappelle at the hollywood bowl
um
it was it was jeff ross hosted he
brought up dion cole and then he brought
up don l rawlings and then he brought up
me
and then there was like a little
intermission and then
jeff ross did a roast and dave did an
hour and then buster rhymes came out and
closed it
um
[Music]
with like chris brown and a few other
one point usher came out there was
[ __ ] insane
but um
first things first it's been a i was i
was [ __ ] nervous
i was like going like all right
this is this is a lot of there's a lot
of goddamn people here right
and uh it's also such a legendary i was
trying to think of all the shows that i
saw there everyone from like
i don't know
like the old school bands
so like peter gabriel and sting and uh
[ __ ] steely dan
i want to say i saw erica badu there a
long time ago but i think that was the
greek
i don't remember i was drinking back
then
um
i saw the stone temple pilots
a long time ago i saw them there
um
i saw herbie hancock there with vinnie
caliyutta on drums
uh
who else remember pharrell opening
and that other guy landed
elvis costello
saw a whole bunch of people then all of
a sudden you then i remember seeing like
there's this classic
story of richard pryor
going on
at the hollywood bowl
and um
it's this amazing story how he went out
there
and it was a show for gay rights
and uh
and he went out on the show
and he opened with he said you know i
sucked at dick once
and the place went [ __ ] crazy
because he got molested or whatever you
know
way when he was younger according to his
book and everything right so he opened
with that
and then everybody was just like oh my
god this is [ __ ] amazing blah blah
blah blah not understanding
the terms with which
he he he did that act and then
they thought he was going to be cool and
all of that and then he just [ __ ]
turned it around on him
and was basically saying why the [ __ ]
should i as a black man give a [ __ ]
about you because where were all you gay
people
during the watts riot
and he slowly
you know a few people understood what he
was saying being like all right fair
enough and by the end the crowd hated
him and [ __ ] booed him
it sounded incredible
it sounded like
a [ __ ] unbelievable just one of those
things the crowd is booing you because
they know you're right
um
i wish i i don't know i wish there was
[ __ ] audio of that somewhere but i i
for the longest time i i had never heard
that story i think it was i was down the
comedy store
something came about where it was like
an anniversary of his death and they
told that story i was like wow so i was
thinking about that
um when i was backstage and uh
had to go on after don l rawlings which
is never easy
never easy you know
i knew he was gonna bring the heat and
he also was wearing a [ __ ] suit
and i was just like oh jesus christ
he looks like he's getting ready
you know a [ __ ] lifetime achievement
award i know he's gonna go up there and
kill so um
and i like an [ __ ] it stayed out till
like one in the morning the night before
and you know my kids always get me up at
like seven so i was tired and i just i
felt a bomb coming
i'm like wait a minute this this might
not go well
and there are a lot of people here to
tell the story so
i was a little bit nervous and then
whenever i get nervous i just start
talking to people around me so i stop
thinking about and i just go out and i
like i don't think
and so of course dion cole kills
of course donald rawlings kills and then
jeff ross is up there and i couldn't
hear because i was from the side he was
doing some sort of some sort of bit
about uh
the the couple that left the royal
family
and he was absolutely [ __ ] murdering
and he's usually you know just stands
there and does his jokes he's literally
laying on the stage just [ __ ]
destroying and i was just like oh god
even jeff is bringing the lumber here we
go and um
fortunately i went out there and uh
it went really well and i got to be
honest with you like i could not see
past
you can only see about 40 50 rows up
thank god because it just keeps going
and going and going and going so um
i remember at the end of the night kind
of when the lights came up i was like
holy [ __ ] there was a ton of people here
but it was such a freaking honor
to be on that show and then dave went
out
and did this super tight hour-long like
for him a tight set is an hour
he did 60 minutes and absolutely [ __ ]
leveled no fat on
on the bone or whatever no gristle it
was just [ __ ]
tight it was great and then
buster rhymes went out and i'm thinking
all right
people came here to see dave
it's the end of the night buster's gonna
go out there he's gonna kill it but you
know
you're only getting him for 20 minutes
so he'll do like a medley or blah blah
blah that's what i thought was gonna
happen
dude that guy went out there
him and and i i would i forget the guy's
name that he goes out with who's it was
absolutely incredible i got to look up
his name i can't i got to give this guy
his due here the hell's his name here oh
hang on hang on hang on hang on all
right the guy's name is spliff star
and let me tell you something those guys
went out there
and just absolutely
[ __ ]
destroyed that place
just leveled it it transcended
that they were rapping like i learned
[ __ ] as a comedian watching them how
hard they [ __ ] killed
the show they put on the sense of humor
that they had
um
the whole thing they just absolutely
[ __ ]
smashed and i got to tell you both of
them
their energy
is 20 years younger than they are
because i was sitting there you know
some of the bands i was saying that i
saw you know sometimes you you know
you see a band that you saw in your 20s
and then you see them in your late 40s
and you know they're still good but they
just sort of remind you
of your mortality it's like they're old
i'm old we're all gonna die
that was not the case
when buster went out there buster went
out there and it was just like this
[ __ ] guy has not even lost and
he hasn't lost anything he was as
amazing as he was way back in the 90s
when i first started seeing him
he absolutely [ __ ] killed
and um
you know i went to the show with nia i
was and i i just kept talking about it
afterwards going like
like how much i what i got out of that
performance i'm so glad
that i stayed because you know i was
[ __ ] tired i was relieved and i was
just like once i saw dave i was like i'm
gonna dip out try to beat the traffic or
whatever and um but dave does a thing in
the end where he calls everybody out so
i was like wow
i don't wanna you know
come back out do a curtain call at the
hollywood bowl when am i an [ __ ] of
course i'm gonna stay for that and thank
god i did because i got to watch his
whole [ __ ] setbuster set and he
absolutely killed us if you get a chance
to see that guy
uh you are without a doubt gonna get
your money's worth that guy is an
absolute
[ __ ] monster monster performance um
you know i guess you'd have to be to
follow what what chappelle did for an
hour which was also
i mean
he just i mean i it's weird thing when
you when you love what a comic did you
can't say what they did because then
you're doing their jokes but definitely
obviously catch dave
um
he absolutely [ __ ] killed it too so
um
anyway
um
yeah that was kind of my weekend and
then i i've been looking at this footage
and [ __ ] and i'm actually learning
finally how to [ __ ] uh i'm getting
into a groove here of how to edit
footage
and everything which is pretty goddamn
exciting
um
i mean i don't know i don't know where
this is gonna lead
or whatever but uh
i don't know i've also gotten into like
drinking coffee and [ __ ] which i never
did
i kind of still don't but this morning i
i went to go hang with keith robinson
because he was in town i also owed him
like 500 bucks because i've lost like
five bets in a row for the guy who's
about 100 bucks i just keep losing
and i've owed it to him since like
during the pandemic and i'm just so sick
of him calling me up being like bro give
me my [ __ ] money i just got sick of
it so i was just finally like where are
you staying
and i just woke up this morning just
drove down and i just gave him the 500
bucks and i was like now shut the [ __ ]
up
he just laughed so we had a good time um
hanging out or whatever
uh
you know that part's going good my
[ __ ]
the rest of the [ __ ] is not you know
oh you know
i'll tell you something right now if you
want to get into a [ __ ]
argument with your significant other
go to a brunch
i'm telling you
you know i was [ __ ] tired
and you know
there's this whole netflix festival
there's this big brunch
and you know i hate shopping and i
haven't shopped since before the [ __ ]
pandemic
i didn't want to do it but i knew i had
to do it and uh
you know it's just one of these [ __ ]
things it's one of those [ __ ] things
that you just have to do as an adult at
some point you have to go out and try on
a bunch of [ __ ] sports coats and
sport coats see what's funny is i go to
the brunch
and most people weren't wearing a sport
coat and i was just like i'm an [ __ ]
you know
i hate buying a sport coat because i
only wear it like twice
there's just so few events that i ever
wear a sport coat to and i [ __ ]
i buy one of these stupid things
and then i wear it like twice
and then the next time i go to wear it
it's already out of style
somehow the cut the color or whatever
and i have all of this [ __ ]
um i don't know what to do with them you
know i still have the suits that i wore
when i when i first did like letterman
like way back in the day and now they're
like out of style and i want to get rid
of them and i was all ready to get rid
of it my wife's like no no no
you're gonna want those someday and i
was like i don't
i don't want them
i i don't
want them
and i have this [ __ ] thing in my life
where i say things and people just don't
hear me
you know do you find that in your
relationship or you're just like do you
want to do this thing and you're like no
i don't and the thing just happens
anyway and you're sitting there like i
said i didn't want to do this and yet
here i am
doing this [ __ ] thing how does this
keep
how do i make my nose
mean no
i just don't know how to do it
jesus christ i gotta be honest with you
i wanted that i was good at that brunch
you know what i mean
because the sport coat will give you
confidence because you can hide a good
30 40 pounds underneath that thing which
is an excuse to go [ __ ] you know
do a little smash and grab up at the
[ __ ] uh buffet there and i didn't do
it
i [ __ ] uh actually left the brunch
hungry
i was like that's that's a good thing
you know go brunch i'll kill you
have you ever seen anybody that
organizes a brunch live past like 60
or what they look like those people who
put like booze in their orange juice
whatever the [ __ ] they call those things
yeah
i mean i don't know i'm talking about
like white people they get like those
that red face
you know like the [ __ ] um
the hypertension face
that's what you end up getting just
going to those
it's just too much [ __ ] right
i'm sorry i'm in a goddamn mood celtics
lost it's bumming me out i taped the
game i didn't want to sit down and
[ __ ] watch it but at least we got we
got past uh
yeah we got past brooklyn so i don't got
to watch kyrie irving step on our logo
again so that's nice
and then uh we'll see what happens here
i like the i like the celtics chances
and even though the bucks won it last
year it's really hard to repeat so uh
we'll see yeah we'll see what happens i
think we win game two
you know i got a little bet going with
uh nate craig
you know he was talking some nice [ __ ]
you know what i mean get i'm getting the
usual [ __ ]
the usual bullshits uh boston being
racist that's always the one oh yeah
boston is racist as opposed to what the
open-minded people in milwaukee
and he's like rittenhouse was from
illinois and i was like i wasn't talking
about him
[Laughter]
so anyways we should be giving each
other a bunch of [ __ ] during the whole
thing which will make it fun
and uh lastly but not leastly for all
you old [ __ ] guys out there old men
and women
like myself
um
i finally got the name of that thing
that i've been using i'm telling you
it's incredible
it's called the shoulder reliever
um
i've been finally putting together like
40 days here where i just use it
i'm telling you that that's that middle
that medieval thing that i've been
telling you about right with the handle
then there's a ball on the end of it and
you're swinging around
like you're in a mad max movie and uh
there's four different weights
each one each ball gets heavier that's
what she said uh each ball gets heavier
and then by the end i guess you're
supposed to feel good so i'm on the
third one and my shoulders feel [ __ ]
great
and uh i'm starting to believe that i'm
going to be able to win my [ __ ] money
in this pull-up bet
it's kind of what i'm hoping
to be honest we'll see we'll see uh
we'll end up seeing what happens with
this thing if i as long as i don't go
crazy in the gym but i've been sort of
hanging from like a pull-up bar with my
feet on the ground stretching out my
shoulders shoulders which also really
helps
but um
you know i just got to make sure i don't
add too much weight
when i'm when i'm lifting or whatever
it's embarrassing
using like five six pounds at least i'm
out of like the colorful ones
that the aerobic chicks used in the
early 80s
you know
i was using those for a while but then i
also realized you know the other day i
took a picture with somebody
that was in their 20s and i they showed
me the picture and i looked at it i was
like i really am in my 50s
you know you know what's weird about
aging is you don't really notice it
because every day you know you see
yourself in the mirror right you're
brushing your teeth you know you're
checking yourself out to make sure you
don't have anything hanging off your
[ __ ] shoe and you just see your face
every single [ __ ] day
and you just do not notice
and then one day you take a picture with
somebody that is the age that you still
think you could pass for and then you go
holy [ __ ] who is that waterlogged
[ __ ] hag
[ __ ] hag next to that person oh my
god that's me
that's [ __ ] me um
anyway let's do some reads here for this
week um as i'm bumming you out about
aging which i hope i'm not uh roman
everybody
speaking of being old
you know what i mean is your dick old
this you know is your dick like
roger clemens the last year he played
for the red sox
would you like it to then turn into the
roger clemens the very next year with
the toronto blue jays
get roman everybody you know when you're
wearing a great outfit everything looks
oh this isn't something for your dick
this is for your suits right
oh no it is no it is this is for your
dick sorry roman everybody you know when
you're wearing a great outfit everything
just looks right and your confidence is
soaring you can walk into a room knowing
you're on an a game if you've been
struggling with p e
uh what is p e
what is p e
roman can give you that same feeling
isn't it e.d what is pe
penis envy
will you make your dick bigger what's
going on here if you're struggling what
the [ __ ] is i gotta look this up
what is pe
here we go
how do you google this to know
what does
let's say physical education pe
stand for
in medicine
here we go
pulmonary embolism i don't think that
that's what it is
all right i'm going to write the worst
word i wrote penis
premature ejaculation
oh [ __ ]
i feel like the last family family
member on on the family feud you know
they always stick the dumbest one
all the way down to the side
and the whole [ __ ] family's just
looking at them as they spit this dumb
[ __ ] out of their mouth then they've got
to be a good answer
that's a good answer it's not a good
answer
and you're not helping them by saying
they're giving a good answer all
right
all right p.e
all right if you wanted a feature length
film but only got a short basically
premature
ejaculation why is everything about a
guy in his dick so embarrassing that we
have to abbreviate e-d-p-e
ah god i needed another one what's
another what's another thing bd
bent dick i guess you have your dicks
like hooked and they're not saying
there's something wrong with your dick i
have no idea fitness look we all know
that change doesn't happen without
action whether you're looking for gains
at the gym or an experience in the
bedroom there's never any shame in
showing up
for yourself and your health so if
you're dealing with pe premature
ejaculation
uh
don't ignore the issue instead face it
head on with roman why can't women take
pe as a [ __ ] compliment
you know what i
mean
it's just you're so hot i already i
already [ __ ] in my pants before we
even took our clothes off
i mean i can't think of a grander
gesture
to talk about how beautiful you
are do you think i'm pretty do you think
i'm pretty
don't know do i think you're pretty
you're out of your [ __ ] i mean i got
to go change my underwears yeah
um
all right guys man-to-man i care about
each one of you this this is what th
these are the words they're putting in
my mouth i want you to feel confident i
do though
i want you walking in there
you know
knowing that the first thing you point
your dick at it's not gonna shoot all
right
i want you to secure the perimeter
um i want you to feel confident and to
prioritize your health in your
relationship if you're ready to do that
for yourself start
with roman
we'd like to have a lot of fun around
here on my channel podcast show
we like to have a lot of fun around here
i like how this is morning dj copy so i
know if you guys are anything like me
you probably dread wasting time in
boring waiting rooms then having to
spend money on a copay then insurance is
a hassle you know how it goes for my
guys out there dealing with pe i have to
tell you about roman why is this a whole
new intro
it's not about in the waiting room and
spending money it's about having to sit
there across from another human being
saying you come too quick it's
embarrassing
and this is what we need to talk about
we need to erase the stigma
of p.e
roman swipes are clinically proven to
help you last longer in bed no
prescription needed
premature ejaculation treatments are
safe effective and used by millions of
men free two-day shipping go to
getroman.com
today if approved you'll get 10 off your
first order that's getroman.com
do you realize if men were like women
not saying we know [ __ ] [ __ ] all the
time
hence my podcast i can guarantee you
that like
if there was some sort of pe version for
women
you know what i mean oh if we were like
them this would be like something like
we need where are the women to support
men
when it comes to premature ejaculation
don't
don't [ __ ] quick come shame me
all right
i'm sorry i'm just in touch with my body
all right stamps.com you know if you got
a small business inflation isn't doing
you any favors right now it's harder
than ever to stay profitable if you're
looking for ways to cut costs mailing
and shipping is a great place to start
simply use stamps.com to mail and ship
and get access to exclusive discounts
and great rates on shipping from usps
and ups
it's an easy way to keep your money in
your pocket stamps.com saves you time
it saves you money and stress no matter
what business you're in stamps.com can
help you save on shipping whether you're
in office sp sending invoices
an etsy shop
sending your products or warehouse
shipping out truckloads of orders
shipping.com is the mailing and shipping
solution for you start mailing and
shipping with stamps.com and keep more
money in your pocket every day sign up
with the promo code burr for a special
offer that includes a four-week trial
plus free postage and a digital scale no
long-term commitments or contracts just
go to stamps.com click the microphone at
the top of the page and enter the code
bur b u r r
um
so there you go let's get into the uh
let's get into the reads here for this
week by the way i saved
that message from
equal luigi
i want to see if i can make that show
happen
and see the northern lights there um
oh this isn't i don't think this it
doesn't happen this time of year
okay sorry keep yawning
sorry i'm old all right zoom everybody
hey bill
hey man he's talking about zoom this is
like the zoom meeting or she is hey man
i'm sick of zoom
i don't want to jump on a zoom call if i
can make a phone call and people are
really starting and people are really
starting to lean into it because they're
sick of their boring desk jobs and need
face to face to liven up their afternoon
i recently yeah i don't get that like
it's becoming that thing though if they
can't see you it's like you're not on
the phone it's like i am on the phone
all right
i'm just gonna sit here with my eyes
closed as i listen to you
um
i bet all corporations are they're all
going to start
every like it's all going to be video
conference because we want to be able to
read your face
we want to see what your face is doing
scan your face scan your retina all of
that [ __ ]
and just see if we can see any
inconsistencies
in the level of loyalty that we that we
demand here
as we deliver soul-sucking information
and instructions
to your side of the room anyway i
recently told someone i don't have zoom
and opted to get on the phone the
reaction over email was loud and clear
they passively aggressively made it
seemed as if we couldn't accomplish what
we needed without it
[ __ ] the zoom
also why am
why is it assumed that i have it hey
[ __ ] come over my house and install it
or get the [ __ ]
out of my email
all right
um that was a lot of a lot of anger in
there but i understand what you're
saying
yeah
the zoom calls and all that i got a
couple people that are in the uh the
corporate world
in my life and it just seemed like i
just don't understand like
i don't feel like corporations value
their employees as much as they're just
like
we're just going to just burn them out
burn them out burn them out burn them
out we don't care about the turnover or
anything we're treating you like [ __ ]
and we're getting every ounce of [ __ ]
work out of you that we can and when you
when you leave we don't give a [ __ ]
because we'll just get someone else to
replace you because we've destroyed all
the mom-and-pop places
um
i don't know that's just my my opinion
and i feel like the zoom call
is another way for them to like gain
information
about where you live how you're living
you know your commitment to the thing
the whole [ __ ] thing is just creepy
um all right trial
um
dear bill
but on the other side i love a zoom call
as opposed to like if i was in the
corporate world and you had to go to
hong kong it's like why can't we just
jump on a zoom we're still face to face
what is the [ __ ] problem you know
pollute the environment less like i'm i
i think that that's
a good use of it i would think but you
know if you guys are just you know
living close by and this guy just says
hey man i just want to be on the phone i
don't look at you why can't you just say
that
listen i don't like doing zoom
if i'm going to be on the phone i want
to be on the phone i don't want you to
sit there looking at me but i think what
they maybe that's what they like about
it maybe they like the fact
that you can't act like you're paying
attention when you're not
because you can [ __ ] mute
zoom and you can mute a phone call but
when you mute a phone call they don't
know what the [ __ ] you're doing
i mean you literally could be doing
anything
you'd be asleep
and they wouldn't no and i don't think
that i think that they like the control
of zoom
and i gotta be honest with you it would
be nicer if it would be the world would
be a better place if more people kind of
rebelled
against [ __ ] like this
um
at least push back a little bit anyway
trial dear bill
i've been watching the depth trial
johnny depp trial every day on youtube
in the background while working it's
[ __ ] awesome bill
watching someone get caught lying is
super underrated
oh i heard he is absolutely destroying
her
um
i'm too big a johnny depp fan to watch
that i love that guy and i just i you
know
i don't want to hear all this personal
details and [ __ ] but from what i've seen
the guy is [ __ ]
destroying and what's great about this
is if he really does expose this woman
for lying
i'm wondering all of these
people that you know
just accepted her lies about him if
they're going to apologize somehow
because they publicly trashed him it'd
be nice if they then publicly apologized
and said maybe next time we won't jump
to conclusions
um anyways he goes it's [ __ ] awesome
bill watching someone get caught lying
is super underrated having someone who
has gone on the record is saying one
thing and then having proof that the
other happened is so fulfilling on top
of all of it you get johnny
effortlessly throwing that hollywood
charm around the
courtroom
i'd love to have it on vinyl i got to be
honest with you my good buddy paul
verses been watching it he just keeps
calling me up he goes are you watching
this he's like johnny is absolutely
destroying her
um
you know i've just heard like bits and
pieces that it really does amaze me
how it just the pendulum just does not
seem to swing the other way
that all of these
women's groups that when they see a
woman that lies like this which really
hurts their position
because there are women out there that
are in a relationship that this woman
evidently
lied and claimed that she was in when
she wasn't
and for someone to go out and lie about
it hurts the people that are actually in
it so you think that they would cover
this and they would also talk about like
you know i remember a guy a long time
ago told me he said if you're in a
relationship with a woman if she ever
starts
swinging on you
lock yourself in the bathroom
lock yourself in the bathroom so
you know
she won't hit you anymore it doesn't
escalate and there's going to be no
evidence of you at some point because
you're going to have to get her off you
you know she can be look at this mark in
my wrist when he
you know because you caught her hand as
she was swinging at you you caught her
wrist then you're gonna get in trouble
you know you're wearing a ring it leaves
a mark you're just [ __ ] done you know
it's like no i just grabbed her arms
because she was swinging at me nope we
have to take you in and all of that [ __ ]
um it just fascinates me that when
there's just a clear example of
something like this that i think it
really hurts
feminism if they want
more men to come along than if they
would actually trash
someone like this
publicly the way that they would go
after a toxic guy because you know i
don't imagine going after toxic guy he's
an [ __ ] i get that
but you know i don't know
for someone to be able to do like if if
this really
goes in the direction that everything
she was saying was absolute [ __ ] and
the level that this guy's career
suffered and the amount of [ __ ] that
happened to him um
if it all just pans out of with a whole
oh yeah
sorry about that
like that's how it's gonna end it just
it just doesn't [ __ ] seem right and
you know what it doesn't sit well with
me
um
so anyway
if i had the time i would definitely uh
i would be watching
more of it i mean versus losing his mind
like he's watching like a seven game
series he thought was gonna be a seven
game series but it sounds like johnny's
gonna sweep
um
which makes me happy you know i like
that guy
um all right superhero movies uh and it
should make even women happy because if
he's innocent then that means that he
didn't make a woman suffer right
um all right superhero movies dear billy
the marvelous
a couple weeks ago you were talking
about superhero movies uh you know
what's funny last night
uh
me and my lovely wife
who's mad at me right now
um
we went to go to sleep and she for
whatever reason put on the hulk
and i was watching it i've always loved
the hulk slash related to the hulk
uh just the anger issues obviously not
the physique or the
science degree whatever dr david banner
you know
whatever
um
i just always hated how it was always
the army going after them they're always
like shooting machine guns at them and
[ __ ]
sound waves and all of this [ __ ]
and uh i don't know i always liked the
hulk
angry misunderstood
[ __ ] person you know
um but i don't get the hulk when the
hulk is chill
and starts shooting the [ __ ] with people
and isn't angry it's like shouldn't you
be turning back into bill bixby
um
but anyway a couple weeks ago you were
talking about superhero movies i'm a few
years younger than you and i also did
not get sue
get super into comics as a kid i dabbled
here and there in a cartoon or a random
comic book it wasn't until i had two
kids and i gotta tell you they ain't bad
um remember that spider-man tv show from
the 70s
where they basically had some guy throw
a rope
from off the screen to look like webbing
yeah throw like a net i remember that
the thing that gets me the most is how
they took 25 movies
and had them all tied together
my kids don't even really get it but i'm
sitting next to them going oh [ __ ] that
ties back to that other one
uh i only bring this up because you've
talked about how revisiting things you
didn't like
i.e the talking heads
no i always liked the talking heads
i just never saw that movie stop making
sense talking heads wasn't one of the
bands i always liked them it was um
i forget who it was it wasn't a talking
head so i always liked them anyways and
realizing you're you judge them too
early i'm very guilty of this i would
say like rem
um
a few like those college bands i mean i
was just some of this
testosterone
medal i mean anything else
after listening to that [ __ ]
at least back then to my untrained ears
just sounded like somebody playing a
[ __ ] ukulele and now when i go back
and listen to some of that
that metal a lot of it is just really
thin and cheesy
i just i thought it was you know this
guy's a [ __ ] badass man
um anyway anyway uh you can't go wrong
with iron man i watched a few of the
iron mans you know john favreau robert
downey jr of course i'm gonna watch that
and honestly guardians of the galaxy is
one of the best movies it's like kelly's
heroes in space kinda give it a few
years and you'll be coming on the
podcast flipping out about them because
your kid loves them also
watching these movies easy on the
back
i don't know what that means
it's not a lot of heavy lifting for your
brain is that what you're saying
um no i'm not
i just
i don't know
they're [ __ ] loud as [ __ ] the last
one i went to i went to superman vs
batman
and i was like i was sitting there like
i should have brought my earplugs
it was so [ __ ] loud and all they did
was just beat the [ __ ] out of each other
there was like a fight it was like a
half hour long and i just want to be
like can you two just [ __ ] already
nobody hates another guy this much like
what are you fighting
and i also do i just don't buy
that superman would have that big a
problem with batman
that's never made sense to me batman is
a vigilante
okay i don't know what sort of [ __ ]
you know
uh grip strength workout this guy does
but you know
he's pretty goddamn strong and then you
also got to say you know for a rich kid
he did all right
usually when you're born into wealth you
know
there's real no sense of urgency unless
you come from one of those psycho
families that wants you to continue
building the wealth and you'll be
written out of the will
then your life sucks
you know you know those [ __ ]
families where you have to take fencing
it's just required because
you know
every
you know [ __ ] griffith fallen iii
knows how to fence going but we can
trace it back to the medieval times like
those [ __ ]
rich kids
those ones
the ones who end up like you know
committing a murder you know
those [ __ ] lunatics back in the day
the billionaires boys club i don't know
what i'm talking about right now but you
know um
let's get back to bruce wayne here
the guy comes for money
he's a slacker he's not really doing any
core workout or even no kettlebell [ __ ]
you know he was probably listening to
the joe rogan podcast and was was going
to order the on it stuff but never got
around to it and then all of a sudden
one day
his parents get killed right isn't that
what happened
his parents get whacked
wait am i talking about ghost
that was patrick swayze that was demi
moore's
um
boyfriend
right
you know i just realized
i remember one time
i was high out of my [ __ ] mind i'd
eaten
i didn't i don't know how many [ __ ]
milligrams of weed right i was high on
my [ __ ] mind and i started thinking
about demi moore and demi moore
and how it was always demi moore
and then out of nowhere
it became to me
and i just started cracking up laughing
wait this wasn't when i was no this was
an acting gig i had
dude i got i got to get off these
[ __ ] cell phones no i wasn't i wasn't
high i was i was improving with the
person somebody brought that up
wait is that a riff from the movie i
mean i think that may be a riff from the
movie i'm editing i gotta find that
thing
i already edited that scene holy [ __ ]
all right this has been a good podcast i
just remembered a joke that i wanted to
throw into the [ __ ] movie all right
sorry people i i'm sure i just [ __ ]
did a little somersault with the brain
there i apologize let's get back to
bruce wayne
right all of a sudden
his [ __ ] uh you know what i would out
of all the scary moves i saw by the way
that have freaked me the [ __ ] out those
[ __ ] things that came up in ghosts if
you were a bad person that dragged you
down to hell there was something about
it because it was sort of a romantic
i can't say comedy
it's not really romantic comedy if uh
the boyfriend gets whacked
you
know in the beginning of it
right
although bambi's mother dies and they
call that a kids movie
jesus christ i'm all over the map here
so
anyway
i think that that's what was more
disturbing well if you're watching like
a [ __ ] horror movie you think it's
gonna be a problem but like if i know
that like you know some dead guy is
gonna make up like a [ __ ] potted
plant with his ex-girlfriend who's still
alive like i just don't think it's going
to be that scary
it just seems like it's going to be kind
of like you know
some living somewhere like flubber or
the shaggy d.a remember those sunday
night disney movies
um with that guy that looked like the
guy from [ __ ] leave it to beaver but
it wasn't
there was two guys there was hugh
beaumont and there was this other guy
and they both looked the same and they
both carried comb their hair the same
[ __ ] way but they were different guys
the guy from my three sons
is that the guy
well bill would help if you had [ __ ]
names all right sorry
um
anyway so bruce wayne's parents get
[ __ ] whacked and then he becomes like
a superhero but like he's not like
he doesn't have super powers
he's just like a he's basically charles
bronson
or charles bronson was batman in death
wish
right anyway so i went that's denzel's
move so i saw that movie and look i i
probably saw a bad one because i like
the spider-man ones the john favreau
robert downey jr ones i like those those
were fun movies
and you know john favreau is one of my
favorite directors and robert downey jr
is one of my favorite actors
so it was kind of cool to see that level
of talent
go into like a big hollywood movie like
that and make a great [ __ ] movie i
also like the um
my favorite one the batman movie there
um where the joker walks away out of the
hospital dressed like a nurse with that
guy from brokeback mountain
right i love that one
that one i loved
you know but i was never into uh
i don't know you know what dude i'll
give him a shot just where am i supposed
to start i bet they got the whole list
of them there's 25 [ __ ] movies this
is the thing about nowadays when you try
to get into something you're always like
500 hours behind and it's just like i
can't i can't do all of this i can't i
don't have [ __ ] time with this
all marvel
movies in order there it is okay here we
go
starts with howard the duck
what
all marvel movies how to watch mcu
movies all right here we go
oh my god i'm gonna do you know
something i actually agree with what
you're saying and i will do this with my
kids someday but i'm not gonna do this
twice
marvel movies in order how to watch all
33
mcu whatever that stands for it's
probably something about a guy who has a
dick problem movies and series
chronologically
all right if you want to see the marvel
and avengers
movies and orders order as they happen
starting with the world war ii set
captain america the first avenger we've
listed all 33 mc movies in a series in
chronological orders in one guide
exclamation point so while iron man set
and released in 2008 can claim the
banner as the first of the marvel
cinematic universe within its story
chris evans has got robert downey jr
beat that's because evan's origin story
as captain america the first avenger
takes action in 1942
wait they didn't put that out in 1942
it's set then right
they're
there we're also first fully introduced
to the
terrace
tesseract
and energy cube oh jesus
an energy cube
oh there's always a sphere or a [ __ ]
cube
or like a [ __ ] isotope
something glowing there's always that's
always that cheesy [ __ ] stupid thing
that now if i throw a face cloth over it
thor this hammer doesn't work anymore or
if i hold it up next to him he [ __ ]
crumbles
he loses his hair and he's standing
there with a tack hammer it's all the
same story climaxing in 2019's avengers
end game
all right did they just list them or do
i have to read all of them right number
one captain america
the first avenger 2011.
all right then captain marvel 2019
that's number two
iron man number three
2008 wait a second this is the order you
have to watch them in
iron man 2 2010
the incredible hulk
number five i think i saw i saw that
one that was the one i was watching last
night
then there's thor 2011 that's six
marvels the avengers
is number seven
yeah this is when it became like ocean's
eleven
but with you know
people on hgh and underwear
thor the dark world is number eight iron
man three
uh
captain america the winter soldier they
got 90
on rotten tomatoes
guardians of the galaxy guardians of the
galaxy vol 2 avenger you guys can look
this [ __ ] up
ant-man with [ __ ] paul rudd
i gotta see that i love paul rudd
captain america civil war
i think i would like uh
oh wait this is captain america versus
robert downey jr scarlett johansson
black widow
spider-man i hate this i love spider-man
and i just hate they always [ __ ] up
spider-man
you know what i mean
i
i just it do his girlfriend in the
[ __ ] it's one of the few
comic books i ever read
was like a raven-haired beauty like a
catherine zeta jones type and i don't
know what the [ __ ] they do in the movies
you know
she had hips she had titties
she was [ __ ] gorgeous right and then
they always get like some [ __ ]
lollipop bodied thin-lipped
i don't know what
and you always just sit there like
spider-man's not [ __ ] that that's you
know peter parker
is not i don't know
i could get her
i can't even do a pull-up anymore all
right black panther
oh that was part of this i saw that one
dr strange
thor number 20. ant-man is back
avengers of finney this is a whole other
thing avengers end game it's number 23.
so the end game isn't even the last one
then you watch loki
what if in 2021 juan davidson
shang chain the legend of the ten rings
now we're going over to asia here the
falcon and the winter soldier
moon knight
spider-man far from home spider-man no
way home
spider-man home on the range no
eternals
hawkeye
dude [ __ ] that i'm not [ __ ] watching
all of that
but you said it was good
i don't
oh my god
um
all right well if i ever do that i'm
going to count the amount of of
cubes spheres and isotopes that glow
that either give power or take power
away wasn't there in in superman's like
sort uh
fortress of solitude
i mean if that doesn't just show you how
much [ __ ] women nag guys he'd have a
fortress
of solitude
this is superman he could fly away from
any conversation he possibly i'm doing
like 80 stand up right now what's the
deal with the partners of solitude um
i don't know
i'll i'll
watch them so batman is not in it
because that's that's
dc right
and that's like the big thing who do you
like better marvel or dc
and generally speaking marvel's the more
mainstream
and dc
is for those people that just want to be
cool right and be like i actually like
this better i actually like what less
people like you know you i used to know
a guy like that that i swear to god
wherever somebody was at he was always
on the lesser side every
single
[ __ ] time and it took me about 12
years to finally figure out being like
oh
he doesn't really feel this
he just does this because that's a way
of keeping the focus of the sub of the
topic on him
rather than what we're talking about
you know what i mean
like you'd be like oh my god aretha
franklin died
i mean the queen of soul
the greatest voice
one of the greatest voices of all time
and then he'd just be like yeah you know
i didn't think she was that good
and then it would we would stop talking
about aretha and it would be like
wha what you don't like how could you
not like you know i just didn't [ __ ]
integer
[Laughter]
and for the longest time i remember just
thinking how is this person always
always on that opposite [ __ ] side and
then i finally i don't know
i think i undid a couple of my own
quirks
and i figured out a few other people and
i was kind of able to all of a sudden
see this person a different way i was
like oh that's what they're doing
oh
that's the way to do it i've seen people
do that
you know
if you want to keep the like if you're
younger and you're around boomers and
all they're doing is just talking to
each other and you and for whatever
reason you'd want attention from them
all you'd have to say is you think the
beatles are overrated
that was it and then the entire focus of
the conversation would be on you
trying to figure out how you couldn't
like
the greatest band of their generation
according to them
um
so anyway
who do you like who do you like in this
celtic series um i mean you kind of
gotta go i mean my heart says the
celtics but you also kind of have to go
you gotta go with the defending champs
right
you gotta feel like that's it's it's
theirs to lose
um
i don't know i mean it would be
incredible if we could get past that
make it to the eastern conference finals
that would be [ __ ] amazing but it's
obviously gonna be tough
and uh i was i'm gonna watch the tape of
the game
after i upload this podcast
because i want to see if there's still
any more animosity
between grayson allen and grant williams
i'm going to keep talking about this
because this is the story that espn
keeps running from they've asked me not
to talk about it
because it's just such a divisive
a polarizing topic
all right but i i will continue to talk
about that you know i don't think grant
williams ever got his revenge
for two back-to-back flagrant fouls
because grace and allen couldn't handle
a soft screen during a summer league
game
he got his ass kicked out now they were
playing in vegas who knows maybe grayson
had some [ __ ] on the side he wanted to
get to and
maybe he had taken his roman swipes you
know and thought he could last a little
longer and he wanted to see if they
worked so he just
decided to pick on grant williams but i
don't think that that's where that came
from
and i think there's a score to settle
here
and i think when the celtics are up
eight points
in game seven to close it out in
milwaukee
i think that's the time you know if
basketball was like hockey but i think
that's the time where you drop the
gloves because there is an art to it
isn't just going around skating around
like a [ __ ] goon there is an art to
knowing when and where to drop the
[ __ ] gloves all right
and uh and also drop the mic which is
what i'm doing now because uh
i gotta go [ __ ]
[Music]
do some [ __ ] as always that's what i
have to do so anyway thank you to
everybody that's coming out to the uh
the la forum
on may 5th um
i think there's only a couple tickets
left can't believe it i can't believe it
i got nervous i get nervous uh but
people showed up so i'm gonna give you
guys a [ __ ] incredible show i am so
excited
to uh to do that i'm also hosting a
stand-up show for netflix at the
palladium on the fourth that's a tv
taping
very excited for that i'll be working
with
i don't know if i'm allowed to say
everything with netflix is so secret but
i i'm i'm working with all these comics
that i admire
uh they gave me a great lineup so i'm
very excited about that too
and uh
and that's it i think that's all i got
so anyways go celtics go bruins red sox
jesus
you know i'd you know what the problem
is is they're not taking any walks
they're just going up there and they're
swinging they got to get some guys on
base and then make these opposing
pitches pitch to them that's what they
need to do they're not just not doing
that
um
we'll be all right though it's early
it's early
it's early on we'll see what happens all
right that's the podcast go [ __ ]
yourselves and i'll check in on you on
thursday